New York senator Kirsten Gillibrand now
says that Bill Clinton should have
resigned over that Lewinsky scandal back
in 1990 is it your view that the
President Clinton should have stepped
down at that time given the allegations
yes that I think that is the appropriate
response but I think things have changed
today and I think under those
circumstances there should be a very
different reaction let's face it the
reason Kirsten Gillibrand has suddenly
found sense is that she's position
positioning herself for a 2020
presidential bid she wants to run for
higher office and it's interesting by
the way how she mentioned Lewinsky but
conveniently forgot about all the other
women who accused Bill Clinton Juanita
Broderick Paula Jones Kathleen Willey
and yes there were many others now when
Gillibrand was running for office in
2006 whom did she call to help her raise
money Bill Clinton of course and she
like many Democratic women before her
had no problem at all turning a deaf ear
to the complaints of sexual assault that
had dogged Clinton for decades and you
know why because let's face it he was an
uber fund raiser he was fantastic at it
but with sex pigs now being called to
account for their misdeeds in the wake
of the Weinstein scandal well Democrats
have suddenly discovered a moral
conscience and now they even see their
former heroes with new eyes Bill Clinton
wasn't a degenerate when he appeared at
every Democratic convention since he
left office and I guess he wasn't a bad
degenerate sexual harasser when he was
fetid in New York at the Clinton
Foundation galas and he wasn't a sex pig
last month when he campaigned for Phil
Murphy in New Jersey but now that his
wife has lost the presidency and Bill is
under new scrutiny he's suddenly a leper
to the party that enabled him for
decades sell it somewhere else none of
us believe it the truth is you have to
question how seriously these Democratic
women take sexual harassment
these are some of the same women who
held a pep rally for Bill Clinton in
1998 after his impeachment I love that
photo a Mount Olympus of female
Democrats were in attendance Feinstein
Pelosi boxer Mikulski all of them
standing and clapping like a bunch of
seals for Bill Clinton the only thing
missing was the fish throwing to them
now this newfound courage among
Gillibrand and the rest is a little more
than political expediency and the
Democratic Party knows what we all know
the Clinton brand is over it's damaged
the Clintons have outlived their
usefulness and the usefulness of the
party is nil so it's safe to throw him
under the bus safe to look away safe to
say that he should have been canned when
he was found out about Lewinsky so
enough with all the glowing praise of
Gillibrand for her brave stand and the
Democratic truth tellers who are now
coming around to acknowledging Bill's
lecherous past they were opportunists
then and they're opportunists now and
that's the angle